I just talked to them outside they're in
the car and I'm like I'm like let's
let's let the best idea win you don't
owe us anything let's have this
conversation and essentially he said you
know
you don't believe in my truths
like this is my truth you guys are
denying it and I don't want to have the
conversation that sounds like left
left BS and I'm like look I disagree
with you like and that's okay
knowing you and if you think you're
right explain it to us that's what I
said I was just running up that's what
I'm like disappointed by I wanted to
hear more from each person at the table
about just what they're doing and what
their vision is because even if you
don't agree with them they're really
interesting and they are doing some
really big things did he make any
suggestion at all that he would come
back at some point no he's like I don't
want to have a conversation with you
guys because you guys you know
essentially the bigger truth of what he
his his or I'm like those are your
truths
the defender side and let the best idea
win let's at least continue the dialogue
and conversation